final fantasy 15 is right around the
corner and I basically know nothing
about it or any of the Final Fantasy
games for that matter in fact the only
Final Fantasy games I've played are 3 7
10 13 and crystal chronicles that may
sound like a decent amount but I didn't
finish any of them and 13 left a pretty
bad taste in my mouth
worst birthday ever for lack of a better
term I'm a Final Fantasy scrub but
considering I was 13 when Final Fantasy
15 or vs. at the time was announced I'm
kind of curious to see how this game
turned out so when we got access to a
final preview bill to the game I decided
to give it a shot and hopefully answer a
question that some of you might have is
it too late to play a Final Fantasy game
Final Fantasy 15 has new characters and
a new story but it's also the 15th main
line game in a series that has been
around for 30 years
[Music]
whether or not you've played Final
Fantasy there's no denying how
breathtaking this game is the vistas are
jaw-dropping the animations look
authentic and the scale is really
impressive not only is the map huge but
stumbling upon massive creatures are
huge monoliths scattered throughout the
world will leave you in awe even if you
don't know exactly what you're looking
at then the art direction certainly adds
to the visuals as well even though the
game is a fantasy game it manages to
avoid a lot of the genres tropes by
blending sci-fi tech with modern
inventions and classic fantasy elements
the Final Fantasy games have been doing
this for a while now but there's
something oddly compelling about taking
a road trip in a fantasy universe that
is strangely similar to our own at times
however the massive scale does come at a
cost I've only played around five hours
and I've spent a good amount of that
time behind the wheel on a chocobo or
just running
[Music]
if presentation and graphics aren't
really a selling point for you you might
have a difficult time getting into this
game but even if you do like visuals you
can only look at a virtual sunset and
sunrise so many times so the question is
how does this game play Final Fantasy's
combat has undergone many changes and
this one is very action-oriented if
you're expecting a turn-based JRPG with
an overworld and random encounters then
you might be happy to know that 15 does
none of these things creatures you fight
and have it the same space as you and
even though areas are sectioned off when
you begin a battle the transitions in
and out of combat are seamless once
you're in combat you'll be doing fairly
typical things like attacking blocking
parrying dodging countering and even
sneaking although it seems kind of out
of place in this game though the combat
itself is hard to compare to another
game it should feel familiar to those
who played action role-playing games
there are also things like link strikes
cooperative moves special abilities and
even spells that you can customize
although all these things are a little
convoluted a lot of these special moves
I flat-out ignored and I never really
felt like the game challenged me enough
to figure them out
as of many RPGs as you progress and
level up you will be able to unlock new
perks and skills for Noctis and his team
now I'm no stranger to unlock trees and
skill webs but Final Fantasy 15s
ascension system is a little bit
overwhelming fans of the series will
probably feel at home with something
like this but I had to spend a good
amount of time figuring out what
everything meant and what I should focus
on and what I should ignore now this
shouldn't come as a surprise but the
hardest thing for me to grasp in Final
Fantasy 15 is the story it isn't
necessarily hard to follow
it's just weird one moment I'm pushing a
car through a desert then I'm picking up
bounties at a roadside diner and then
I'm camping in a coma in tent cooking
eggs all while wearing black leather in
the desert although I kind of like the
quirkiness and attention to small
details that don't really matter but at
the same time isn't there a throne I'm
supposed to be taking because I don't
really think thumbing through pictures
is gonna help
and after 14 mainline games and dozens
of spin-offs Final Fantasy 15 has a
pretty well-established lore behind it a
lore that couldn't be more foreign to me
and I'm not even talking about the movie
and anime based around these characters
speaking of the characters five hours in
and I don't really like any of them they
don't even really seem like friends to
me just members in your party but like I
said I'm only five hours in in a game
that's supposed to be very very long so
hopefully that changes
there's a lot I don't understand about
Final Fantasy 15 and I'm sure some of it
will never make sense to me but after
the time I spent with the preview build
I really want to play more
I'm sure fans of the series will find
things that they love and things that
they hate but as someone who's never
particularly been invested in this
series now seems like a pretty good time
for me to start playing Final Fantasy
for more on Final Fantasy 15 in all
things gaming
stay tuned to game spot